and what about toxic masculinity
generally do you believe in that what my
initial understanding of toxic
masculinity was the unrealistic societal
expectations put on men that were toxic
to masculinity because masculinity
itself is not toxic but there's all
these like societal roles that are put
on us that's the toxic thing I think
that that's just manipulating the term
or trying to get your way of it because
like you said there's nothing wrong with
a man being a man experiencing his anger
or aggression or his ability to fight
because fight or flight is necessary for
all of us you don't want to eliminate
that in a man when we need it we need it
the whole man up thing that's toxic
masculinity instead it's now being used
as like a discriminatory thing
true Geordie podcast